the vast majority of news in the u.s. is
controlled by five huge corporations and
news voice is fighting back against
media monopolies it's the first-ever
entirely open crowd-sourced democratized
platform for news use the link right
underneath this video to download the
news voice app for free so I was
checking up the president's tweets
yesterday and I noticed Donald Trump's a
quote great job by congressman Doug
Collins of Georgia over the weekend in
representing the Republican Party and
myself against the impeachment hoax and
I thought what the heck let's see what
Trump's talking about if he liked it it
must be really weird in case in point
Republican congressman Doug Collins was
on Fox News Sunday over the weekend and
it is everything that we could have
imagined and more Doug Collins goes on
the strangest word salad in defense of
Donald Trump and it makes such little
sense that I actually decided to
transcribe it for you which we will put
up on the screen momentarily this is
what Donald Trump liked from Doug
Collins the factory is their corruption
so I do not spend dollars that I don't
need to spend in the Ukraine because of
corruption it was still there okay this
is an issue let me just ask you I
thought experiment that just just bear
with me for a minute if you believe that
the President had used the power of his
office to try to get Ukraine to
interfere with our elections if you
believe that would that be an
impeachable offense I do not believe it
so I'm not going to answer a
hypothetical and which is designed to
simply say that the president did
something improper Chris he did nothing
improper there was nothing about a
problematic giving aid to another
country in which you're talking about
corruption which he's required to do by
law and he just so happened that a
presidential candidate son who was
getting in a massive amount of money
from a company that had been under
investigation in which even other
witnesses that have been favorable quote
to the Democrats in the investigation
have said needed to be looked at this is
a problem of overall proportion but
there's nothing here that the president
did wrong and this is the thing that
we're going to move forward on okay yes
so you really have to look at a
transcript to see how whacked this is
and I transcribed it take a look with me
this is what Doug Collins said quote I
do not believe it so that I'm not going
to answer a hypothetical in which is
designed to simply say
a that the president did something
improper Chris he did nothing improper
there's nothing about a problematic
giving aid to another country in which
you're talking about corruption which
he's required to do by law and he just
so happened that a presidential
candidate son who is getting in a
massive amount of money from a company
that had been under investigation in
which me even other witnesses that have
been for favorable quote to the
Democrats in the investigation have said
to be looked at have said needed to be
looking at sorry
this is a problem of overall proportion
but there's nothing here that the
president did wrong and this is the
thing that we're going to move forward
on I have no idea what this guy's
talking about if anybody knows what he's
talking about let me know now I
understand he's defending Trump and he's
suggesting that Donald Trump did nothing
wrong like I understand the tone of it
but I don't know what the hell this
guy's talking about now it's possible
that he and Donald Trump both speak
whatever language that is which is why
some people understood what Trump meant
by cop feffy and Trump presumably
understands what this guy said but it's
got to be just the tone it seemed like
this guy was strongly defending Trump
and I guess that that's good enough for
Donald Trump there's nothing about a
problematic giving aid to another
country in which you're talking about
corruption which he's required to do by
law and I started thinking to myself you
know what has happened to education in
our country what has happened to
critical thinking in our country but
Doug Collins went to college he also has
a master's degree sort of it's a
master's in divinity from some seminary
but still it's a master's degree Doug
Collins is a lawyer he has a law degree
and this incoherent word salad defense
of Donald Trump is the best that he was
able to muster up either something is
very wrong with Doug Collins or he's
simply struggling to defend the
indefensible and his brain couldn't
handle it so it resorted to something as
nonsensical as this and and what you
just heard the saddest thing about all
of this is that people who want to
defend Donald Trump will watch this
video
and they won't understand it because it
doesn't make any sense of course and
they'll say to themselves you know this
Doug Collins guy he seems super smart
and I just don't really understand
politics he must just be talking in a
way that is above my head
I'm sure he's making sense many trumpets
will assume despite the fact that this
guy is making no sense whatsoever but
it'll be enough for them a strong
defense of Donald Trump Trump was happy
with it
Doug Collins seemingly pleased with it
even though it makes no sense whatsoever
that's what Trump like that's what Trump
found to be a great job done by
congressman doug collins the discourse
has been debased and i'm worried there
is no return at least no return anytime
soon